when you watch media right now who do
you trust
I wouldn't put all my eggs in one to ask
it one way or the other there's very few
people who bring the meat potatoes I
think a journalist is somebody that the
more division there is the more money
they make let's just face the truth and
who holds them accountable do we hold
people accountable for exercising their
freedom of speech we have a relationship
you're the expert I'm not the expert I
don't have time to go run a research and
do everything your facts can all be
right but the story is still wrong the
truth is somewhere in the middle right
people are addicted to their outrage
they want to be angry every day I think
would freak the average person how to
have their emotions removed from their
political beliefs
that's like tearing someone's religion
or whatever you have the emotion not you
the journalist I don't want you to have
the emotion I want the journalist to
tell me the truth
you
[Music]